how's it going everyone it's Warren and
it's time for Theory Thursdays on a
Friday I pushed it back because of the
awesome Avengers in-game second official
trailer that we got yesterday I was
super excited to hear everybody's
theories about what is going on in this
trailer what everybody thinks is
happening and what everybody thinks is
going to happen in Avengers endgame but
before we go into these theories a big
shout out and congratulations to Aiden
Jost for being the winner of February
8th and one week three and the month of
February with his theory on how Avengers
in game is going to go down which
includes a big infinity stone battle at
the end of the movie Congrats Aiden you
get a gift card for two imax tickets
alright let's kick off week 2 of March
with some awesome theories about the
Avengers and game trailer that was shown
yesterday theory number one comes from
Chris and he thinks that ant-man is
going to play a huge role in Avengers in
game Chris says I think ant-man is going
to play a major role in endgame in my
theory he escapes the quantum realm at
least one to two years into the future
when knots hair is the long red braid he
rushes to the home of Cassie and her
parents to realize it's been empty for a
while the lawn and hedges are very
overgrown trash has heaped on the curb
and old weathered missing person posters
cover every space on the pole he goes
back to his office he goes back to his
home he tries to find somebody that can
fill him in I think he finds Cassie who
tells him what she knows and Scott
realizes he has to get to the Avengers
he learns though they had already tried
to fight Thanos with new help months
after the snap and failed again and no
one has heard from them since Scott
decides to return to the quantum realm
and take a new vortex and get out closer
to the snap either through hit and miss
or guidance from somebody inside of the
quantum realm perhaps dr. strange Scott
gets out three months after the snap he
drives across the country and gets to
the Avengers headquarters where Nats
hair is still short and blond
Tony nebula and Captain Marvel have
already arrived he's suddenly in on the
initial battle against Thanos because
it's about to happen when he gets there
before he has time to tell them all that
he knows after their loss again they are
now ready to listen to Scott's
information he brings with him Pym
particles his suit in possibly
directions from contact
with Hank through a past time vortex on
how to create the suits Tony takes often
develops a multi-purpose quantum realm
slash space suit for all the Avengers
while NAT goes to find Clint thorn
rocket find Valkyrie and Captain Marvel
recruits scroll and other cosmic allies
so this is Chris's theory and I think
that it makes a lot of sense primarily
because I don't think ant-man is going
to get it right jumping through a time
vortex the first time he's not going to
automatically land in the perfect time
he's going to get it wrong at first
because at first he won't have any
control over the time vortex but I agree
that he will eventually have control
over a time vortex somehow and that is
when he'll go to the Avengers
headquarters and fill them in on
everything and I do personally think
that the Avengers are going to fight
Thanos more than once in Avengers in
game I do think they'll lose at first so
I think that this theory makes a lot of
sense
so that's theory number 1 on to number 2
number 2 comes from Andrew Gutierrez and
Andrew has a theory about Hawkeye in the
Avengers in game trailer Andrew says
that in the trailer when we see Hawkeye
with his daughter shooting the bow and
arrow I believe that this is the scene
in the movie where they will show
hawkeye's family get dusted this is
where we get the backstory of him taking
on the Ronan persona it fits well with
everything because it would stay within
the first 15 to 20 minutes of the movie
as well he isn't a part of the first
theorized battle with feyo's just like
in man and this will give the
opportunity to fill an info with what
happens to Hawkeye during and after the
events of infinity war leading up to
when he meets with Natasha and Japan I
agree with this theory I think that's
exactly why they showed us this scene in
the trailer because in this scene we're
going to see Hawkeye lose his family to
the snap and of course they'll tell the
story about how Hawkeye becomes Ronan in
Avengers in game and they'll definitely
tell us what he was up to during the
events of infinity war so that's theory
number 2 on to Theory number 3 theory
number 3 comes from a tall and a tall
says that we know by rumors that in
endgame Tony and Bruce and maybe Sheree
will join forces to build a weapon which
can harness the power of the Infinity
stones to reverse Thanos a snap but they
don't know how to build it as the
gauntlet was also not capable and it was
destroyed after the snap so Bruce and
Tony will work on Loki's scepter which
at all thinks we can see in the
background of
this scene right here from the trailer
they'll work with the scepter because it
used to contain an infinity stone the
mine stone they brought it to the
Avengers headquarters so they can try
and understand the mechanism of it
because it used to contain an infinity
stone
so that's a toff theory and there is
definitely something in the background
of this scene if the Avengers have
Loki's scepter somehow it would make
sense that they would study it not only
did it contain an infinity stone but it
did harness the power of it so this
definitely makes a lot of sense if that
is Loki's scepter in the back the
Avengers are going to have to figure out
some way to harness the power of the
Infinity stones if they want to use them
so that's it for theory number three on
to theory number four number four comes
from MJ and MJ has a theory about the
Hulk coming back MJ thinks that the
scene with rocket on rody shoulder and
nebula screaming from the trailer
yesterday is when they first fight
Thanos and Avengers in game they lose
the fight and banner still can't get the
Hulk out so he asked Tony and nebula to
help him out they used some technology
and merged the two into one and that
Hulk is Professor Hulk then professor
Hulk gets in his quantum suit time
travels and we see him run with the
Avengers in Wakanda like we saw in two
trailers for infinity war and Hulk
finally gets his rematch
I like this theory I like that the Hulk
still doesn't want to come out he didn't
want to come out at the end of infinity
war and not much time we'll probably
have passed from that time and another
fight with Thanos and the technology
aspect is kind of what makes Professor
Hulk professor Hulk in the comics he's
actually known as the merged Hulk for a
while and I am one of those people who
thinks that the footage that we saw for
the Avengers infinity war trailers with
the Hulk running in Wakanda could show
up in Avengers in game and I definitely
think that by the end of Avengers
infinity war the Hulk is going to get
his rematch with feyo's so that is
theory number four on to the final
theory number five theory number five
comes from rpm newbie Pro and rpms
theory is that Thor will search for a
tree in order to forge more weapons now
that we know that fan oohs will hold his
double-edged sword and the Infinity
hammer thanks to some leaks we know that
each tree is indeed active I believe
that considering we saw that Captain
America is a little bit worthy to move
you'll near in age of Ultron maybe he
will receive a weapon of his own and
perhaps Carol Danvers will receive a
great weapon as well this is something
that I've actually talked about before
and agree with in the fear itself' story
The Avengers actually travel to
neduvaali R Odin grants them permission
to the forge and all of the Avengers get
new weapons made out of uru metal I
don't think that all of the Avengers
will travel to neduvaali R but it does
make sense that Thor would go there and
try and get new weapons especially if he
thinks that Captain Marvel or Captain
America is strong enough to wield them
so I think this could very well happen
in Avengers in game so that is it for
this week's theories let's do a quick
recap theory number one was about
ant-man going through the time vortex
finding the Avengers eventually fighting
with them and losing to Thanos and then
telling them about the time vortex
theory number two stated that in the
Avengers endgame trailer that we just
got yesterday and the scene with Hawkeye
and his family this is the scene where
we see him get dusted theory number
three was about Loki's scepter and how
the Avengers would be studying it
because it will did an infinity stone
and that it is also in the Avengers and
game trailer theory number four is about
how the Avengers will go fight Thanos
early on in the movie but the Hulk's
that won't come out so with the help of
Tony and nebula we get professor Hulk
and theory number five was about Thor
going to neduvaali ER to get more
weapons for the rest of the Avengers so
those were this week's theories be sure
to vote on which one you thought was
your favorite and if you would like to
submit a theory of your own for your
chance to end up in an episode of Theory
Thursdays you can find the email to send
it to and the instructions in the
description down below again don't
forget to vote on which one was your
favorite and don't forget to subscribe
to my channel to stay up to date on
Theory Thursdays and everything related
to Marvel as always thank you all so
much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]